Inside they very large eyes of a squid
are spherical lenses.
Usually, spherical lenses can’t bend the light
that passes through them enough for
the image to look focused,
but these cephalopods found a way around that.
Their lenses are built up of proteins
called S-crystallins.
Two loops on the surface of this protein
allow it to self-associate into a gel.
Slight variations in the protein
changes the loops and how they link.
The types of links vary in a gradient along the lens –
denser in the middle and sparser at the edges
This gradient arises during development.
At the larval stage,
the proteins are packed together in bundles of 6 —
forming the dense gel core.
When particles can no longer
diffuse easily through the core,
the proteins form a layer with fewer linked
S-crystallins on the outside of the core.
This continues until the outermost layer,
made with just pairs of proteins, completes the lens.
This change in density across the lens
allows light that passes through the center of the
lens to bend differently than light that falls on the edge,
thus focusing what would’ve been a blurry image.
The S-crystallins in squids’ lenses
act like “patchy colloids.”
These are groups of molecules that exert
attractive forces on one another and can form complex
shapes out of repeated units,
just like the bunches of S-crystallin proteins.
With these findings and further research,
scientists think squid lenses could eventually
be replicated with simpler materials
and used in optical instruments and clinics.